so for our second introductory talk
which is entitled redefining
intelligence we are pleased to welcome
Carl Lyman who is the 2001 Nobel
laureate in physics and he has also
spent a quarter of a century thinking
about science education and how that
should proceed in the future so Carl
Wyman okay well I'm just going to to
talk a little bit about rethinking what
we really mean by intelligence and I'm
focusing on the the human aspect and my
main point is to think of it is
something that's really created rather
than some inherent characteristic and
I'm gonna start with a definition that
that I use which is really the ability
to do complex worthwhile cognitive tasks
worthwhile is judged by what people see
as important so I have to say I don't
rank jeopardy as very high on the
intelligence scale but looking at the
human brain I mean it's been
biologically it's been the same for you
know many thousands of years and so that
raises the question of can its
intelligent really be enhanced and the
argument I'm gonna make very briefly and
not much nuance today is that yes it can
be by by enhancing the learning of it
and as we understand how the brain
functions and learns we can really
enhance its learning and thereby its
ultimate intelligence so start with that
there's a long history of people working
on developing ways to measure sort of
basic ability and they're thinking
better is that natural ability or
intelligence IQ at some reason and then
establish from that what the
corresponding limits are on people's
cognitive capacity and the idea that you
can do this
frankly is mostly supported by a
combination of myth and a mixing up a
prediction with cause so you give a
bunch of kids IQ tests and then the ones
that get a score high you give them
special teachers the ones low you give
them crummy teachers and then lo and
behold later on the ones who scored low
in an IQ test do worse in school so you
decide you have predictive ability
that's not of course that's cause not
really prediction effect and so the the
overall evidence is that you can do this
is really basically weak and the reason
it's hard to do these kind of
predictions is two reasons and I'm
coming at those as really the the basic
justification for my whole rethinking
about this problem is the the first
problem is that the results from your
tests they should correlate with
recognized worthwhile accomplishments
people can ultimately do and you'd like
them to correlate strongly these days
they're people who work in this they're
happy to get kind of any modest
predictive statistical capability but
secondly if the these IQ tests are going
to be measuring something fundamental
they they shouldn't be easy to improve
on just by practiced at the test and
both of these are quite hard to achieve
particularly the latter one and so this
is an example of what sort of I'd say
good or among the best results in this
field of person looking at people's
performance on this complex video game
this is a air traffic controller
simulation having people practice this
over time and seeing how much this a
collection people how much better they
get here and having given a whole bunch
of tests of ability and IQ that seem
related to this and you know this is the
average but with in here there's plus my
is 10% or so fluctuation and these
initial tests can predict about 25
percent of that variation so in this
field so that sounds good
but then you think about
the effect of practice here is far more
than that amount of variation and so the
the whole point I'm getting at is really
practice always and as as it does in
this case dominates over the predictive
value of something like ability or IQ
and it gets the and it gets even worse
in terms of how poorly the predictions
are compared the impact of practice as
the tasks get more complex and as the
learning takes longer and so the the
basic point I want to make is that
really there may be other things that
matter but they're always small compared
to the ultimately the quantity and
quality of the training or practice or
learning if you like of what people are
trying to do and you see these same
curves over and over for pretty much
everything you can measure in terms of
what you want people to do including
these complex worthwhile tasks that I
would our start out with and so based on
this as the coaching and training has
improved you find ways to improve the
quality you'll find this ways to make
this go up faster and to hire here and
we see this improvements over you know
over the decades in athletic performance
music virtuosity even things that you
might think are more fundamental memory
as people have have learned to train
memory better over factor just the last
20 years the records for memory capacity
have tripled now those seem like sort of
basic kind of mechanical things but
getting closer to my own work we find
that even things like mastering
application of physics concepts we can
find better ways to train ie teach
students on that and we can double so
instead of going up like this they're
going up here to twice the height by
finding better ways to teach them so
this kind of enhanced learning it really
requires a
deeper understanding of what's really
involved in these cognitive tasks the
the how the brain thinks about them and
how it learns them and then you have to
figure out how to put that into the in
Denis instruction and practice for the
learners and so we're still fairly new
really in this field I'm working across
areas there but I want to give you a few
air examples we probably the best data
really is from the kind of work I mean
where we look at post learning of
science at the post-secondary level I've
already mentioned we made great strides
and how people can better learn learn
physics concepts and other others in
science looking at a more lower level my
colleague Dan Schwartz has looked at how
the brain processes and thinks about
numbers at a very basic sense and
realize that by teaching children in
terms of teaching about negative numbers
teaching them to think about this as a
model of symmetry as a reflection of the
positive numbers scale he's actually
being able to improve by their measures
about 50% in the capacity of children to
understand and use negative numbers in
other areas again back to really in my
own work and people lie you're doing
looking at the testing the validity of
scientific models we've been able make
dramatic improvements at people's how
experts like students can become at
doing that in the same amount of
learning time and finally touching a
little on creativity coming up with
creative mechanisms reasonable
mechanisms and creative ways to explain
novel biological processes we've done
dramatic ways to improve the learning of
that as well and so just to finish I'd
like to argue that really I see the
future of human intelligence is very
directly related to the idea of this
enhanced quality of learning of complex
skills that we can reach higher levels
more rapidly
make this much more widespread above a
population ultimately really reaching
higher levels than of expertise than we
have now and then ultimately this really
does mean increased human intelligence
thank you